♪Share the spice of life.♪
ZINKE OF SEEKING TO HIRE THE
BEST PEOPLE FOR JOBS AT THE
INTERIOR DEPARTMENT WITHOUT
REGARD TO THEIR APPEARANCE.
THAT WAS THE KYRON.
ZINKE ANGERS BY HIRING THE
BEST.
RIDICULOUS.
HIRED BY ZINKE.
BUT THE LEFT STILL REACTED
WITH HORROR.
KRISTIN CLARK LAWYER FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS LIBERTY UNDER
LAW.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I KNOW I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR ANYONE ELSE.
WHEN I SAW THAT CNN REPORT
THAT RYAN ZINKE WAS DARING
TO HIRE THE BEST PEOPLE, I
THOUGHT WHAT IS THIS COUNTRY
COMING TO, HIRING PEOPLE ON
THE BASIS OF RELEVANT
CRITERIA LIKE EXPERIENCE OR
SKILL, COMMITMENT, I MEAN,
THAT'S JUST WRONG.
AND I THINK YOU WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT.
>> NO.
WE WANT PEOPLE WHO ARE
QUALIFIED AND EXPERIENCED.
SPECIALTY HYMN OF OUR
SPECIALTY -YMN OF OUR
SPECIALTY --MN OF OUR
SPECIALTY -- H OF OUR
SPECIALTY -- HYMF OUR
SPECIALTY -- HYMN OUR
SPECIALTY -- HYMN OFR
SPECIALTY -- HYMN OF OUR
NATION'S FEDERAL AGENCY.
WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE AGENCIES REFLECT
THE GROWING DIVERSITY OF OUR
COUNTRY.
I'M NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT
RACIAL DIVERSITY, I'M
TALKING ABOUT GENDER
DIVERSITY AND ETHNIC
DIVERSITY AT EVERY TURN WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE
SEEN EFFORTS TO TURN THE
CLOCK BACK.
WE KNOW THAT DIVERSITY IS
NOT A PRIORITY FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHETHER WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT CABINET
LEVEL APPOINTMENTS OR
JUDICIAL APPOINTMENTS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS ONE
THAT HAS NOT PLACED A
PREMIUM ON DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THE NFL?
DO YOU LIKE THE NFL?
>> THAT'S A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
>> Tucker: OH, IT IS.
BUT DO THE SAME STANDARDS
APPLY THERE?
I MEAN GUY THEY GET A PASS?
THIS IS A REAL QUESTION.
WHY DO THEY GET A PASS ON
THE DIVERSITY THING IN THE
NFL?
IS THERE A REASON?
>> WELL, WHEN WE LOOK AT THE
COACHING RANKS, THERE IS A
LOT OF WORK TO DO.
>> Tucker: I'M TALKING ABOUT
THE PLAYERS.
SLOW DOWN.
GREAT, I'M ON YOUR SIDE.
BUT, THE PLAYERS, IT'S ALL
MALE.
IT'S DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFRICAN-AMERICAN.
DOES THAT BOTHER YOU?
>> NFL IS A SPORT.
IT'S A MALE SPORT SO I'M NOT
SURPRISED IT'S ALL MALE.
>> Tucker: DOES IT BOTHER
YOU?
WHY DO THEY GET A PASS FROM
THE NORMAL?
THEIR POINT IS THEY HIRE THE
BEST.
ACTUALLY I THINK THE NFL
DOESN'T CARE WHAT COLOR YOU
ARE.
THEY JUST WANT THE BEST
PLAYERS.
IS THAT OFFENSIVE WHEN YOU
WATCH IT?
ARE YOU THINKING I CAN'T
WATCH THIS, THEY ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE DIVERSITY
RULES?
>> WHAT REALLY BOTHERS ME IS
MY TAXPAYER DOLLARS, YOUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS GOING TO
SUPPORT FEDERAL AGENCIES
THAT DON'T REFLECT THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR COUNTRY,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT WHEN
YOU FLY ON AN AIRPLANE, DO
YOU THINK THAT AIRLINES
SHOULD APPLY THE SAME
DIVERSITY RULES YOU ARE
CALLING FOR HERE, THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T TAKE THE PEOPLE
WHO SCORE THE HIGHEST ON THE
PILOT TESTS BUT THAT THEY
SHOULD HIRE ALSO ON
APPEARANCE, THE WAY PEOPLE
LOOK?
>> EVERY WORKPLACE.
>> Tucker: PILOTS AND HEART
SURGES TOO.
>> SHOULD HIRE THE BEST BUT
PLACE A PREMIUM ON
DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: WHICH IS MORE
IMPORTANT THE WAY THAT YOU
LOOK OR WHAT YOU ARE CAPABLE
OF DOING?
SO WHEN YOU ARE FLYING A
PLANE, HOW IMPORTANT IS IT
WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE, YOUR
APPEARANCE?
>> INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
>> Tucker: APPEARANCE IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
>> ALSO IMPORTANT WE PLACE A
PREMIUM ON DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: BUT DIVERSITY
MEANS APPEARANCE, WHAT YOU
LOOK LIKE.
>> NO, NO, NO.
>> Tucker: TALKING ABOUT THE
SHALLOW POSSIBLE CRITERION,
LITERALLY YOUR SHADE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
WHY IS THAT MORE IMPORTANT
THAN TALENT.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT MATTERS,
TUCKER.
WHAT MATTERS IS THAT YOUR
WHITE DAUGHTERS AND MY BLACK
SONS CAN TURN ON THAT TV AND
SEE AN ADMINISTRATION THAT
REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR COUNTRY.
GENDER DIVERSITY, RACIAL
DIVERSITY, ETHNIC DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: REALLY WHAT
MATTERS TO ME IS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS RUN BY
COMPETENT PEOPLE AND IF THEY
ARE ALL PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
I DON'T CARE WHERE THEY ARE
FROM.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT'S SHALLOW AND YOU
ARE ARGUING IT IS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP
APPOINTEES HAVE BEEN
VIRTUALLY ALL WHITE AND ALL
MALE.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
THIS REMARKABLE SINCE THE
REAGAN YEARS.
AND OUR COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE JUST NOT
GETTING ANYWHERE WITH ME.
IF YOU CAN ARGUE ONE OF THEM
IS DOING A BAD JOB I WILL
AGREE WITH YOU.
SOME OF THEM ARE NOT THAT
IMPRESSIVE I WILL BE
COMPLETELY BLUNT WITH YOU.
IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE BECAUSE
AGAIN I'M NOT A SHALLOW
PERSON.
I DON'T JUDGE PEOPLE ON
THEIR APPEARANCE JUST AS I
DON'T JUDGE BOOKS ON THEIR
COVERS.
I TRY GET DEEPER ON THAT.
WHY AS A SOCIETY WE HAVE
DECIDED THE SHALLOWEST
POSSIBLE MEASURE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT.
DO YOU EVER STOP AND ASK
YOURSELF THAT.
>> DIVERSITY IS ONE AMONG A
NUMBER OF FACTORS.
>> Tucker: DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE IT.
SOUNDS LIKE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
>> TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHEN IT
APPOINTS CABINET LEVEL
POSITIONS ALL THE WAY DOWN.
WE WANT A FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT REFLECTS THE DIVERSITY
OF OUR COUNTRY.
GENDER AND RACIAL DIVERSITY.
>> Tucker: I WANT TO BE
TOTALLY CLEAR IF YOU MEAN
LIKE DIVERSITY OF SKILLS.
I'M TOTALLY WITH YOU.
WHEN YOU WERE LITTLE DID YOU
EVER THINK YOU WOULD BE
ARGUING TO JUDGE PEOPLE
PRIMARILY ON HOW THEY LOOK?
>> YOU KNOW, I'M TALKING
ABOUT GENDER DIVERSITY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT RACIAL
DIVERSITY, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
THOSE ARE OUTWARD SIGNS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
JUDICIAL NOMINEES HAVE BEEN
WHITE MALE.
>> Tucker: ARE THEY BAD?
LIKE YOU ARE SPEAKING A
FOREIGN LANGUAGE TO ME.
>> HE KNOWS NOTHING ABOUT
HOW FEDERAL COURTS OPERATE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A PROBLEM.
LOOK, I'M WITH YOU THERE.
YOU SHOULDN'T EVER HIRE